welcome everyone and thank you for
joining us for today's webinar better
knowledge better care precision medicine
for any cancer any assay on your
platform presented by dr. Cheryl Elkin a
chief scientific officer at n of 1a
kaijin company and dr. dan richards vice
president biomedical informatics at
kyochon my name is Susie Valdes and I'll
be your moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by lab
roots and sponsored by kaya gen for more
information about our sponsor visit them
at wwk I am calm before we begin I want
to remind everyone that this event is
interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen type those questions into
the drop-down box our speakers will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
any trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box and let us know you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located on the top right
corner of your presentation window and
follow the process to obtain those
credits now without further ado please
join me in welcoming dr. Cheryl Elkin
and dr. dan Richards I will now turn the
presentation over to them welcome thank
you
dan Richards what I will talk about
first and start us off here is an
overview of kaijin clinical insight
which is a platform kaijin provides for
the interpretation of variants from next
generation sequencing both for cancer
and other rare diseases our focus today
will be on somatic cancer testing and
interpretation and with that let me give
a brief overview of how this hygiene
clinical insight fits into the overall
workflow laboratory testing for
hereditary or somatic cancer
so basically samples come in to the lab
there's a test menu that's supported by
QC I interpret somatic cancer myeloid
neoplasms as well as hereditary cancer
carrier screening and other applications
or supported you can use any sequencer
to perform your sequencing
although qci also provides a optional
secondary pipeline analysis pipeline
called Kusa analyzed for translating
your raw sequencing data into detected
variants that you can use whichever
sequencing analysis pipeline you prefer
and QC I interpret takes a test product
configuration which is a set of genes or
biomarkers copy number of fusions
whatever you may be looking for in your
particular assay as the input along with
patient case metadata for example to
enable specific clinical trial matching
so information in a case such as the
patient's age and gender demographic
information beyond their diagnosis for
example as inputs and then it applies
the the content that I'll talk about
briefly in terms of information from the
clinical literature practice guidelines
and other sources to put those
alterations that are detected by
sequencing into the context of the
cancer they are detected within to
produce a final report that can be
signed and returned from your lab to
physicians that are ordering it
we also provide a reporting policy that
streamlines that process or automates it
to a large degree based on the 8 amp
guidelines for interpretation reporting
somatic variants so some of the
challenges that are faced in doing this
interpretation of the alterations that
are detected in tumors and putting them
into context and deciding which ones to
report out are twofold one is
determining the biological relevance so
whether they drive tumor progression or
not so that in a standard terminologies
notion of pathogenicity it's trying to
certeyn which ones are activating
mutations in oncogenes for example or
loss of function mutations and tumor
suppressors that may be tested on the
somatic cancer panel and there's a
constantly growing number of
publications that characterize the role
of different alterations in tumor
Genesis functional studies and case
reports for example as well as frequency
information from various sources both
for help identify which variants are
common in the general population and the
germline and can be removed for those
reasons as well as clinical case reports
of the variant in tumors from patients
the second aspect is clinical relevance
or the actionability so not all
pathogenic alterations and tumors can be
treated currently the actionability is
specific to the diagnosis of the patient
so there may be things that can be done
for non-small-cell lung cancer patients
alterations that are not on indication
for example for a patient with a rare
type of cancer but actionability is
considered in terms of what therapeutic
options the patient may have clinical
trials that may be available for new
treatments but also prognostic
significance of various alterations in
terms of the outlook for their ability
to survive the cancer and diagnostic
significance in some cases for blood
cancers for instance and so keeping up
with all the changes in drug labels and
the trials and the consequent growing
of clinical studies is makes
comprehensive and up-to-date reporting
both for pathogenicity and actionability
a challenge and that's one of the things
that kaijin addresses with products such
as guides and clinical insight as we'll
talk about later in this presentation
and of one offering of for
interpretation as well so every month
there is several new cancer drugs
approved
there's hundreds of clinical trials that
open and then there's typically hundreds
of trials that stop recruiting whether
either temporarily or due to completing
the trial across the many sites that
offer these and there's a every year
over a year there's a constantly growing
number of publications on somatic
cancers so all these are some of those
challenges are referred to in terms of
current knowledge that's needed to bring
to bear to interpret the somatic
variants so for the clinical testing lab
there's a couple challenges you need
consistent reproducible interpretation
across the team of providing the report
product you need immediate access to
current information about actionability
of the alterations you need transparency
or visibility of the underlying evidence
that support the treatment options and
support what's reported out and your
final reports and there's a need for
simplicity and fast turnaround time as
well as guideline compliance and so
that's one of our focuses at Kaizen is
really helping ensure high quality and
consistent reporting across all the labs
performing interpretation using our
products
so based on the guidelines there's their
guidelines from amp and ACMG for
germline testing there's also that
pertain primarily to pathogenicity
that's assessing whether the variant
drives disease progression and so
variants can are put in the categories
from pathogenic to benign one of these
five categories each on the
actionability side there are tears
according they have guidelines for
somatic testing that indicate to what
degree a particular alteration or
variant biomarker can be indicates a
particular treatment option and so
there's strong clinical evidence tears
there's potential clinical significance
and then there's similar to variants of
uncertain significance service variance
in the pathogenicity context they're
tier three or unknown clinical
significant variance in actionability
context and likewise appear for
correspond to likely benign and benign
variants so kaijin clinical insight is a
product that's delivered on the Internet
it's secure it it takes as input the
alterations detected by next-generation
sequencing and puts them into biological
context it supports many different
indications both rare and hereditary
diseases hereditary cancer but what
we'll focus on today is somatic cancer
oncology testing both for blood tumors
myeloid neoplasms as well as solid
tumors are supported so briefly what is
kaijin clinical insight it's a web
delivered application you can upload
your the parents detect in each sample
along with the metadata for each case to
the system through API soar if your
lower volume through the user interface
I it lets you see each alteration the
context of the current evidence that
Coggins curated for you and and through
computationally meet computational means
puts those alterations into context so
it's what we've referred to this as is
evidence-based clinical
decision-support software its assists
you in the classification reporting of
alterations independent of which
next-generation sequencing platform you
use it provides comprehensive annotation
and literature resources so it diplay
displays the information about the
alteration in terms of its its relevance
in the particular cancer type reported
clinical cases in the cancer type of
prognostic information about outcome for
patients with that alteration when it
exists in literature that we've curated
as well as treatment options and
specifically matched clinical trial
options it's fast and automated so it we
apply the the guidelines and have a
means to apply that in an automated way
to give you a draft report from which
then you can review and refine if you
see fit to get to your final report in a
streamlined way and it provides this
treatment and trial identification so we
keep up to date with the latest NCCN
guidelines all the drug labels as
indications are expanded and new drugs
are approved all those things are
curated and available and automatically
matched to alterations you detect so
they can be included on your reports and
we also provide customized reporting as
part of QC I many of our customers use
QC I to generate their final signed
reports there's a state mechanism so you
can identify which reports are ready for
sign out do the review and do the
lecture electronic signature we also
through our services provide
customization of the reports so you can
have essentially the report look any way
you like it
it put the relevant and we can help put
the relevant content automatically into
the report template for your particular
test product
so this is all powered by Chi Jun's
knowledge base and which enables Kaizen
clinical insight and it standardizes the
high quality clinical evidence that we
curate from the biomedical literature in
terms of primary evidence from the
figures and tables and the tech
supplementary information from articles
as well as from other sources such as
practice guidelines and drug labels
guidance approach is quite unique in
terms of we capture the information not
just as typed in sentences for example
with gaijin clinical insight but in a
structured manner that structured manner
enables the evidence to be written out
so speak automatically in templated
English like this example what we call
finding a natural language generation
from the structured evidence we captured
into a knowledge base but also enables
it to be used computationally and so
that the power of the computation is
that when you provide a variant to the
system the system can automatically take
that structured knowledge and compute
the ACMG classification dynamically
compute the current amp classification
without somebody having to manually
update each of those all the time since
there's many hundreds and hundreds of
thousands of variants and constant
change in terms of new evidence and new
implications for treatment and trial
matching this enables us to cover a very
broad breadth of information about
alterations and their clinical
significance and clinical actionability
in a very streamlined automated in high
quality consistent way and so aside from
the kaijin knowledge base will require
aid from the primary literature and
guidelines in our streamlined way we
also integrate other sources external
databases and clinical trial sources
like clinical trials gov we curate as
well as drug labels to create a
comprehensive view of relevant evidence
for interpretation of somatic variants
and the knowledge base is updated weekly
so
there is new you know new clinical
trials open and close and weekly basis
as reflected drug labels indication
expansions an approval new primary
literature is constantly being published
and that we curate as well as the
roughly quarterly depending on the
particular cancer type drug guidelines
update we keep those up to date as well
and so all that information sits in
cottage and clinical insight and when
you send it the particular alterations
you detect in your tumor sample it
immediately applies that current
knowledge in the framework of those
guidelines to put those alterations in
the context and produce a preliminary
report so the product itself once you
look at a particular case you can sort
of see a list of the cases in the system
that are pending sign out or pending a
review when you open a case you see a
user and face along these lines it has a
tile for each alteration that's detected
in the tumor it supports sort of the
wide variety of alteration types
including single nucleotide variants in
Dells copy number changes fusions as
sort of things as well as things like
tmb status and MSI status can be
provided to the system as well and each
alterations put into this computed
classification both for actionability in
terms of which tier in the particular
diagnosis for that tumor is appropriate
based on available treatments and trials
and other evidence as well as the
pathogenicity classification based on
whether the variant drives tumor
progression
so for any variant you can click on it
to see the evidence supporting its
classification and so in the amp context
for action ability within the diagnosis
there's a wide variety of criteria in
the amp guidelines for somatic
interpretation it shows you which those
criteria are met there's a in the user
interface there's little links to the
evidence which you can click on to get
more information in the primary source
material that we curated the evidence
from you can also get a summary of the
particular criteria both for action
ability and for pathogenicity that come
from the guidelines these you know those
acronyms at the beginning the 1a is tier
1a the PA one is one of the about 30 or
so criteria in the guidelines for
pathogenicity classification for example
and these just let you see at a glance
the lines of evidence that support the
classification of actionability and
pathogen st which enables a quick review
for variants that you may be seeing for
the first time which is quite common so
mention you can click on the evidence
for any criteria to see the supporting
sources so that brings you directly to
the literature cited that we curated the
evidence from and it also shows those
sentences rendered out from the
structured computable knowledge that we
curated that support the particular line
of evidence of a particular criteria and
shows you sort of a summary of the
primary evidence that was curated
I also provide this ability to customize
your report so we provide a sort of
default report template it has the
general information about the patient
the specimen and a client that ordered
the case lets you provide a overall
report comment if you so choose
summarizes what was detected in terms of
positive results for the case and then
provides the table of particular
alterations that were detected
information such as the wheel fraction
and the which therapies were approved
for the patient's cancer type as well as
are available for other cancer types for
reference in clinical trial top clinical
trials that are most suited for the
patients that take into account both
eligibility and ineligibility criteria
in determining those top trials follow
on pages have information about the
particular clinical trials locations and
contact information things like all
summaries of the alterations and
additional supporting evidence for the
assessments that are made in determining
the final report again this these
templates are customizable and so if you
launch a new somatic cancer panel the
kaijin services team would be happy to
help customize the look of the the
report you could generate a QC eye to
your particularly laboratories
satisfaction qci has been used for many
hundreds of thousands samples by
laboratories worldwide
QC is available in most of the world
currently and it's gone through several
independent validation studies by
leading sequencing laboratories and that
sort of compared their prior sort of
fully manual approach to the streamlined
automated approach that qci provides and
we have extremely high from those
analyses without those loudsound very
high concordance and
determining which variance to report and
the the relevant content both in somatic
cancer and courage very cancer testing
as well as a significant time saving so
the qci since it provides all this
evidence current evidence and context it
vary greatly streamlines the time it
takes to produce a report review and
sign it out relative to other means of
sort of manually searching for some of
that evidence or trying to collect it
oneself in an independent way
so overall kiss I interpret standardizes
a next-generation sequence and
interpretation and reporting it
automates the guidelines which provides
scalable standardized and reproducible
means to do interpretation reporting of
these type of tests and it requires very
little upfront effort since essentially
all this information is pre curated it's
all at hand so you can relatively adopt
the guidelines as well as through QG I
have access to all this current
information to produce actionable
clinical reports in a very efficient way
and with confidence too because we
provide full transparency to the
supporting clinical evidence and we have
over 20 years experience of curating
primary evidence from the clinical
literature with a high degree of
accuracy and high degree of
comprehensiveness and so that
standardized clinical decision support
and reporting for any next generation
sequencing assay sequencer platform or
pipeline to produce those variants
so we recently announced the acquisition
of nf1 this is one of these sort of the
leading company in providing a manual
review of somatic variants and it's a
complement to what we provide with
kaijin clinical insight which lets you
have quite a degree of flexibility in
terms of deciding which variants to
report and refining the clinical trials
for example in doing things in a
semi-automated way nf1 provides sort of
a refined product directly and Cheryl
will talk about that next but overall it
the kaijin provides the knowledge that
powers actionable insights for both
germline and somatic cancer and we have
a number of solutions here with qgi
interpret which would just provided
overview of let's you do the analysis of
variance and interpret them produce a
final report there's other products like
HTM d and engine of your analysis that
assist in that process - for secondary
analysis if you're developing a new
pipeline that you want to validate we
recommend considering QC I analyzed
there's also the bio medical genomics
workbench that hydrogen provides to take
that raw sequencing data and translated
it into variant calls copy number calls
Fusion calls for example and next I'll
transition us over to Cheryl who talked
about and of ones offering which is
on-demand curation and clinical
interpretation service that we offer
so with that show it's all yours
thank you very much Stan for the
terrific description of qci and a great
lead-in to and of one as Dan mentioned
and of one is now part of kaya Jen
bringing our clinical interpretation
solutions to complement qci solutions so
who is an of one and of one has been in
business for over 10 years and we have
grown and evolved with the field of
precision medicine we were founded in
2008 when we began working directly with
patients and their physicians to help
them identify the most appropriate
molecular tests for their tumors
actually helped them to get the tests
done and then explain the results so
that the doctors would have a way to use
those results to help their patients and
through the process of working with
individual patients and of one began to
establish a knowledge base of biomarkers
of genes of variants in the context of
different cancer types linked with the
drugs that have either emerging or
established evidence that they could
target those biomarkers by 2012 we had
begun working with large hospital
systems and commercial laboratories
taking in the results of patient
molecular tests and providing reports
fact that the hospitals and laboratories
could then sign out and by 2016 we'd
partnered with over 30 clinical
laboratories to provide this clinical
interpretation which brings us to 2019
when n of 1 join kaijin having generated
reports for over a hundred thousand
patient cases with it and having
established a deep knowledge base that
covers over 1,800 genes and over a
hundred thousand unique variants that
have been curated and analyzed
so what value does nf1 bring to our
partners why do they like us our reports
are prepared by an experienced team of
PhD scientists that are supported by a
team of practicing oncologist so our
oncologists review all of the clinical
data that we collect and analyze and
describe for clinical validity we rely
on people process and Technology we have
a sophisticated proprietary knowledge
base with proprietary curation tools
that help our scientists to curate the
literature efficiently and accurately
and we utilize a method of knowledge
engineering that facilitates efficient
and accurate report generation so that
information can be stored in one place
and used in many places our process both
our curation and our software
development is controlled by a quality
management system ensuring both high
quality and reproducibility our product
is highly scalable because of both our
but because of both of our knowledge
engineering and the economies of scale
derived from working with many clients
we are able to return reports quickly
and expedite the sign-out process for
our clients who can simply review the
reports and sign them out they don't
have to go what we provide all the
references so they can check whatever
they want to check but they are not
required to do their own work to read
all of the literature and pull together
what are the most important pieces of
evidence we integrate securely and
seamlessly with our clients using either
SFTP or web services and we integrate
with any bioinformatics solution
including QC s so looking looking at the
over a hundred thousand cases that nf1
has reported on over the last eight
years why is clinical interpretation
important why do you need something like
nf1 over the last 20 years the number of
different treatment options for patients
has grown exponentially where as 20
years ago you might think of her - and
to assume a banned breast cancer maybe
EGFR was starting to emerge as a
biomarker and
own cancer those numbers have increased
dramatically over the last 20 years
however only a small percentage of cases
of cancer cases actually qualify for an
fda-approved therapy based on a
biomarker and when you look at a
distribution curve looking from on the
far left at the percentage of cases
where there is an fda-approved drug
that's predicted where responses could
be predicted by a biomarker all the way
to the far right where there's no
targeted therapy available it turns out
that only 16% have an fda-approved
therapy that's the most applicable
option and this number could even be an
overestimate because in most in most
types of cancer because non small cell
lung cancer about 20 to 25 percent of
cases have targeted therapy options that
are covered under the guidelines and so
that draws the average up in 21 percent
of cases there were no targeted
therapies that were appropriate for
patient but in the center of the curve
63% of cases could qualify for a
clinical trial or off-label use of a
therapy and these are the cases with the
most critical need for clinical
interpretation because identification of
the variant alone is not sufficient to
support a clinical decision the
physician needs to know whether that
specific variant is likely to predict
sensitivity to a therapy what is the
evidence that that variant is actionable
what is the evidence to support the use
of that therapy in that disease type and
which clinical trials are available that
the patient can access and this is the
solution this is the problem that nf1
addresses
so where does end of one fit in this
workflow the maroon box labeled clinical
interpretation shows the end of one
position and if one is not a lab we do
not do any sequencing we don't do
sequence alignment variant calling or
filtering the bioinformatics pieces you
can do using QC I and if one starts at
the point after the variants have been
called in filtered and if one can
receive a filtered list of variants from
any bioinformatics partner and then
provide annotation of the variants with
evidence for that their activity
association with therapies prognostic or
diagnostic relevance and that
information is assembled based on
reporting logic that is included within
our platform we generate a report and
send to the pathologist for the review
and sign out
so and of one can report on any type of
cancer solid tumors team Hamada logic
malignancies lymphoma and from tests
derived from any platform or tissue
source FFPE CT DNA etc the reports are
specific to the cancer type and
generated on a per patient basis we
provide links between the biomarkers and
targeted therapies or immunotherapies we
provide prognostic and diagnostic
information particularly for Hamato
logic disorders and always provided with
the relevant scientific and clinical
evidence but so that are the information
we provide is very transparent you can
see exactly where it came from all of
the references are provided along with a
summary of the information the reports
also include a multi variant analysis so
if there's a combination of variants
either with imaging or between different
genes that results in a different drug
sensitivity or resistance than for any
of the individual variants alone that
summary of that information will be
provided and it'll be highlighted in the
report any effects on multi variant
analysis on prognosis or diagnosis are
also included again very important
intimate illogic disorders the reports
also include clinical trial matching the
clinical trials are provided for each
variant in the report they are filtered
by molecular eligibility by age and
gender and prioritized separately for
clinical specificity and geographic
specificity there are some patients that
are unable to travel and want need to
enroll in a trial that's close to their
home or in their physicians own
institution there are other patients
that may have a rare biomarker and they
would like to sort seek out a trial that
may not be geographically co-located and
so we provide both of those types of
prioritization most of the tests that we
interpret our next-gen sequencing tests
but we can also bring in results from
other types of testing from platforms
from fish immunohistochemistry copy
number analysis cytogenetics and we can
integrate the report the results from
all of those differ
test into a single report so again in
heme disorders where you may have
cytogenetic results a send out flit
three and a next-gen sequencing test
though those can all be integrated into
a single report so that the implications
of all of those tests can be weighed in
the in the report
so nf1 offers two different reporting
solutions off of our same database and
really giving the same type of report
one is fully automated and one a semi
automated and again they're drawn from
the same knowledgebase using the same
reporting logic so either the rapid
insights or the precision insights
reports both are of the same high
quality the rapid insights report is
fully automated they can be turned
around in seconds two minutes with a
with a full report
if the variant hasn't been previously
curated within our knowledgebase it's
returned as variant not curated so that
there's no question between a variance
that is unknown in the literature versus
a variance that the end of one scientist
simply haven't analyzed before however
those reports if a client receives a
report with a variant bacteria can be
reflux to n of one for full curation and
n of one does keep track of the variance
not curated that come in if any variance
comes in more than twice it is placed
into a queue for curation so that the
next time it comes in it goes out
automatic automatically the precision
reports are semi automated so anything
that already information that's
up-to-date in our system and meets all
of our time and quality standards would
be automatically assembled and any new
variants or new genes and disease
contacts would be curated on-demand and
the turnaround time for the precision
insights reports varies by panel size
from hours to up to three days maximum
the average for all of those reports is
less than a day and for those reports
every variant would be curated
so the reporting that we do similar to
the guidelines used by QC I we report
using the guidelines described in lis at
all in 2017 and the the amp ASCO cascade
lines it's a tier based reporting system
with levels of evidence that are defined
in that in that paper
and are to give you a sense of our
workflow you know a test may be
performed the results are combined with
with case information a diagnosis code
an a gender location by state or
physician zip code and compiled into an
nf1 report request XML that's standard
across all of our clients and that's
transmitted into the end of one system
using either secure web services or SFTP
our process is entirely HIPAA compliant
but we in we don't actually exchanged
any pH I it's not necessary to the
reports and we we don't generally pull
them in at all and then our reports are
delivered either as a PDF or in most
cases as an XML and for the XML all of
the information we're providing is in
discrete data elements that allow our
clients to design or assemble their own
report and the end of one implementation
team assists with implementation and
mapping of those data elements from our
XML into the client report and we do
provide our PDF to those clients as well
for validation purposes and for clients
that are not ready to produce their own
report or they don't wish to
differentiate using using our report we
are able to we do produce a PDF set that
can also be used
so I'd like to give a couple of examples
of what the reports can show and what
what they actually look like and this
first example is a case of a 51 year old
woman with non-small-cell lung cancer
and as you can see on the report is
divided into tiers and we have tier 1
tier 2 in this case there were no tier 1
mutations and there were no variants of
unknown significance the tier 1
mutations would be mutations with strong
clinical significance therapies that are
approved by the FDA for that alteration
there were none of those in this case
but there were 3 tier 2 alterations in
NRS cdkn2a and RB 1 and for each
alteration we show the gene the specific
variant that was identified therapies
that would be approved to target this
alterations that this specific
alteration in this indication therapies
that have been approved in other
indications along with the level of
evidence in parentheses and whether or
not any trials are available if there
were any prognostic or diagnostic
variants in this case that were relevant
in the specific the disease they would
also be shown in a separate table
guidelines would also be shown on the
front page if there were guidelines
specific for this cancer type they would
be shown but the guidelines are only
shown if they're relevant within that
cancer type so in this case an N Roth
variant would have guidelines that are
relevant in colon cancer that would be
summarized but for non small cell lung
cancer there are no relevant guidelines
this report also highlights the multi
variant analysis showing the interaction
cdkn2a is under investigation as a
predictive biomarker for cdk4 6
inhibitors but requires wild-type
RB 1 for the mechanism of action and
there's also an RB 1 mutation in this
report and so the interaction summarizes
that information and provides references
for for that for that data
and there were no variants of unknown
significance or benign variants those
would be tier three or tier four so
they're not shown here
and so as you move deeper into the
report we show more and more specific
information and so I'll walk quickly
through one variant from this report to
give you an idea of what the information
looks like in this case it's an
activating and Rask mutation and the
first the first section the biomarker
results summary is intended to give the
take-home message what kind of a
mutation is it what is it due to the
gene what effects does that have
biologically are there any drugs
available to target that alteration or
does it have any prognostic or
diagnostic significance and that's
summarized in a couple of brief
sentences of the physician wanted to
read only one piece of information they
could read the biomarker results summary
and get the information they needed but
each section that follows gives a little
bit more so that if a physician is using
a report to support tumor board analysis
or if you know they're unfamiliar with
this mutation and we we've determined it
to be an activating mutation they can
read the molecular function section and
understand exactly what is the evidence
that supports that information so the
biological relevance is divided into
molecular function and incidence the
molecular function describes what does
this variant do what is the evidence it
provides references for all of that to
61 L in n wrath disrupts gtp hydrolysis
results in constitutive activation of
the mutant protein and that's all
supported by references as well
incidence of this gene in this disease
type the data is derived from cosmic
from TCGA as cataloged in the C bio
portal and also from the scientific
literature
the next sections get more into the
clinical relevance of the of the
alteration in this specific disease type
so looking at role in disease this
section provides information for cancer
in general and also for this disease
specifically and if there's very
specific information about the specific
variant it would be concluded here as
well
describing what role does this play does
this gene play in cancer it activates
pathways down screen stream in lung
adenocarcinoma may be exclusive of other
drivers etc and then the next section
looks at the effects that this mutation
or other mutations in this gene could
have on drug sensitivity and drug
resistance and it could be downstream
effects looking at MEK inhibitors or map
kinase inhibitors to target and rath
which can't be targeted directly it also
we ought also look at the effect of this
gene could have unresisting to other to
other drugs
and then getting even deeper into the
information we provide clinical evidence
that is summaries of specific data from
clinical trials that supports the
summary information that came earlier
this information is specific to this
particular disease so in this case
specific to non-small-cell lung cancer
and organized by the phase of the
clinical trial from which the data is
derived will present the highest level
data for any given drug we would not
show phase one data for a drug for which
we're presenting Phase two data we only
show preclinical data if it's very
specific for the disease of the variant
or for a newer novel therapy that has
already advanced into the clinic we
provide a list of sample therapies the
name the brand name if it's been
approved the level of evidence according
to amp and the target or rationale for
use as well as the highest level of
clinical development how far has it
advanced through clinical trials
and then as I mentioned earlier the
clinical trials are presented five trial
to list the five trials for each
biomarker the trials come primarily from
clinical trials gov but can also come
from a few private sources and the
trials are matched based on on either a
single biomarker or multiple biomarkers
so the the filtering of trials would
take into account if this if it were if
there were picked three CA mutation and
it said may not be used you know the
trials not eligible or the patient is
not eligible if they have a k RS
mutation that trial would never be shown
for a patient with a K Roth mutation and
the trials can be prioritized by
institution they're filtered for age
gender disease and then again subjected
to the different prioritization rules by
clinical specificity in terms of
stepheson specificity for the disease
for the particular variant or a
particular type of variant within that
gene and then separately for the
geographic specificity now I'd like to
walk through a couple of other cases
just to show to highlight a couple of
additional features of the nf1 reports
and one of the key components that comes
from n of one is the very specific
variant classification and district
description that's done from the reading
the literature and evaluating all of
that data detailed and accurate variant
characterization is critical for
physicians to be able to make the best
treatment choices for their patients so
in the first example we're looking at a
series of reports for non-small-cell
lung cancer with EGFR mutations and in
this first case the patient has the most
common sensitizing EGFR mutation which
is L 858 R level a evidence for using a
number of different therapies if you can
see the guidelines are cited because L
858 R is specifically mentioned in the
guidelines and non-small-cell lung
cancer
and that was a tier 1 variant however
not all EGFR mutations are the same in
the second case we have a non small cell
lung cancer with an unusual III 30k
variant so mostly most physicians would
never have seen a patient with this
mutation it's not on the label for EGFR
targeted therapies
however biochemical studies have shown
that this is an activating mutation and
in this case the variant is displayed in
tier 2 the therapies have either level C
or level D evidence and they would be
available either off-label or through a
clinical trial and although the EGFR
targeted therapies are not specifically
approved for this mutation they may
still be a good option for the patient
and the specific information supporting
both the biochemical description of the
mutation and any clinical evidence
that's available would be provided to
the doctor in contrast another uncommon
EGFR mutation are 1031 l could be
detected and this is a variant of
unknown significance it's never been
reported before it hasn't been
functionally characterized and for this
variant EGFR targeted therapy is not is
likely not the best choice because it's
unknown whether this variant would
predict sensitivity or whether it's
simply a polymorphism so the N of one
report is providing the evidence to
distinguish between the tier 2 e 330 K
where EGFR inhibitors could be a good
option or and the tr-3b us R 10:31 L
wear a different possibly chemotherapy
or immunotherapy would be might be a
better approach but it's providing all
of that information so that the
physician can weigh it and make that
decision
and in this in another example we have
an fgfr3 s 249 C mutation in a bladder
gira C allele cancer and this in this
case we're showing how nf1 can provide
clinical evidence to support these of
therapies that may not be approved in a
particular context so fgfr3 s 249 c is a
well-known activating variant several
tyrosine kinase inhibitors include fgfr3
among their targets and of varying
levels of evidence to support their
efficacy as an fgfr3 targeted therapy so
the clinical evidence presented
describes the efficacy of the therapies
in a specific a clinical setting as they
have been tested so this is a bladder
year as the ileal cancer case and phase
2 data is presented for drugs studied in
Euro seollal cancers drugs that have
been studied in the context of fgfr
mutations in solid tumors as well as
drugs studied in the context of FGFR
mutations specifically in your athili
all cancers so a physician can weigh
that information and decide whether they
think that a trial of an F G of a kinase
inhibitor that targets fgfr3 might be
the right decision for their patient and
the available drugs are shown in a table
ordered by their level of evidence
and then finally the nf1 reports can
also highlight rare but highly targeted
mutations with droughts that may only be
accessible through a clinical trial so
before the approval of l'air attractive
n track fusions had been identified as
clear drivers and certain cancers and
then tracked in eben Lara tracked and it
were available only in clinical trials
so the drug table shows the level of
evidence for the available therapies and
distinguishes between therapies that
have a higher level of evidence versus a
lower level of evidence so crizotinib is
a drug that's been approved by the FDA
and other molecular indications for
Alcon Ross fusions but only has levelled
the evidence for n tract fusions it
hasn't it hasn't been approved for
intrusions in any indication although
biochemically it's been shown that it
could potentially target and track
fusions however the the then
investigational drug flare attractant
abandoned rec tanam were in active
clinical trials specifically for n track
fusions giving them a level c evidence
according to the guidelines described by
amp so the data and the report supported
the selection of a clinical trial of n
Sestak of an investigational therapy
potentially over an off-label
alternative and the trials are then
presented to the patients or that the
trials have been presented in the report
so that though doctor and the patient
can consider whether that may be the
best option and in the XML version of
the report there's more detail on each
of the sites so that a trial such as
this one which has many many potential
sites the patient may be able to find
one that's nearby
so to summarize nf1 can transform
molecular results into actionable
insights supporting physicians decision
making at the point of care and end of
one joins the family of cryogen products
along with kaijin clinical insight hgmd
and ingenuity and together these
products power actionable insights for
both germline sequence and somatic
sequencing data these products are
highly complementary qci supporting
in-house curation taking advantage of a
vast curated database to drive
computation of pathogenicity and
actionability and of one picking up
providing comprehensive variant
interpretation report writing
integration of results for multiple
assays in a scalable platform
the kaijin bioinformatics solutions
allow the user to proceed from a fast
day file to a clinical report using
best-in-class components for secondary
analysis using qcaa CCI analyzed in this
genomics workbench variance analysis and
classification using QC I interpret hgmd
and ng ingenuity variant analysis and
deep comprehensive on-demand clinical
interpretation from nf1 the kaijin
products can truly take the process from
sample to insight from DNA extraction
library prep and enrichment to
sequencing to bioinformatics secondary
analysis variant interpretation and
clinical reporting providing a single
solution from end to end and with that
we would be happy to take your questions
thank you very much
and thank you dr. alkane and dr.
Richards for that informative
presentation I'd also like to thank kya
team for making today's educational
webcast possible as a final reminder dr.
Elkin and dr. Richards will follow up
with any questions you've submitted via
email that's all for now and thank you
for joining us we will see you next time
bye bye